find the slope of the line in the graph
and just as a bit of a review slope is
just telling us how steep a line is and
the best way to view it slope is equal
to change in Y change in Y over change
in x over change in X and for a constant
this will all or sorry for a line this
will always be constant and sometimes
you might see it written like this you
might see this triangle that's a capital
Delta that means change in change in Y
over change in X that's just a fancy way
of saying change in Y over change in X
so let's see what this change in Y is
for any change in X so let's start at
some point that seems pretty reasonable
to read from this table right here from
this graph so let's see we're starting
here let me do it in a more vibrant
color so let's say we start at that
point right there and we want to go to
another point that's pretty
straightforward to read so we can move
to that point right there we could
literally pick any two points on this
line I'm just picking ones that are at
nice integer coordinates so it's easy to
read so what is the change in Y and what
is the change in X so first let's look
at the change in X so if we go from
there to there if we go from there to
there what is the change in X my change
in X is equal to what well I could just
count it out I'll go I went one step two
steps three steps my change in X is
three and you can even see it from the
x-values if I go from negative 3 to zero
I went up by three so my change in X is
three so let me write this change in X
Delta X is equal to three and what's my
change in Y well my change in Y I'm
going from negative three up to negative
one or you could just say you could say
one two so my change in Y my change in Y
is equal to positive two let me write
that down change in Y is equal to two so
what is my change in Y for a change in X
well when X when my change in X was 3 my
change in Y is 2 so this is my slope and
one thing I want to do I want to show
you that I could have really picked any
two points here let's say I didn't pick
let me clear this out let me clear let's
say I didn't pick those two points let
me pick some other points and I'll even
go in a different direction I want to
show you that you're gonna get the same
answer let's say I see this is my
starting point and I want to go all the
way over there so what is my let's think
about the change in Y first so the
change in Y I am going down I am going
down by how many how many units 1 2 3 4
units so my change in Y in this example
is negative 4 I went from 1 to negative
3 that's negative 4 that's my change in
Y change in Y is equal to negative 4 now
what is my change in X well I'm going
from this point or from this x value all
the way let me do that in a different
color all the way all the way back like
this
so when to the left it's going to be a
negative change in X and I went 1 2 3 4
5 6 units back so my change in X is
equal to negative 6 change in X is equal
to negative 6 and you could even see how
when it started at an X is equal to 3
and I went all the way to X is equal to
a negative 3 that's a change of negative
6 I went I went 6 to the left or a
change of negative 6 so what is my
change in Y over change in X my change
in Y over change in X is equal to
negative 4 over negative 6 the negatives
cancel out and what's 4 over 6 well
that's just 2 over 3 so it's the same
value you just have to be consistent if
this is my start point I went down 4 and
then I went back 6 negative 4 over
negative 6 if I view this is my starting
point I could say that I went that I
went up four that I went up 4 so it
would be a change in Y would be 4 and
then my change in X my change in X would
be 6 and either way once
again change in Y over change in X is
gonna be four over six two-thirds so no
matter which point you choose as long as
you kind of think about it in a
consistent way you're gonna get the same
value for slope